i'm actually happy i got that no
oh i'm
roy i mean i still am looking for news
exactly i prefer no to yes i agree i
really do i'm
incredibly motivated
um
by both which is why i'm motivated
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vaynernation good morning good evening
good afternoon happy travels hope the
dog walking is going well the treadmill
whatever you're doing as you're
listening to this very exciting episode
for me
i had a very substantial hypothesis
when the nft space kind of kicked off in
my brain
a little over a year maybe even a year
half ago
one of the things that stood out to me
is
the real world and the digital world
i have a big belief that a lot of our
collectibles will be sent to warehouses
and we'll be trading nfts
and then one of the biggest bets i made
in kind of my big investing era
of last summer was into tom sacks
rockets
because tom was a very successful
artist danny cole was an emerging
artist in real life that i fell in love
with and that's why i went heavy on
creatures and many of the people
that i supported um
do physical art and then put out
projects but
me as many of you know that have
followed me i've talked a lot about this
me as a non-physical art collector
or enthusiast or
aficionado has you know ironically been
sucked into caring a little bit more
about real art which has been fun um but
along my journeys over the last 15 years
there was you know kind of one artist
that i was aware of that i kind of
watched from the sidelines grow
his you know uh demand his reputation
watched him move we shared a very very
very close friend to both of us named
eitan sugarman who owns hunt and fish
club and
white horse tavern and you know people
that listen to this podcast may may know
the boy from new york uh in in my social
content things of that nature and his
content and so i had a i had a i would
call it a second row seat to watching
roy build his career over the last
decade
and um
when he when he hit me up a couple
months ago and said hey i'm
i'm entering this space
with his friend mike and i was like this
is just so exciting for me
it allows me to really kind of
you know support him to be frank because
i've always wanted to but i tend to be
pretty authentic i buy the things i like
nfts i like and so
what i really want to focus on in this
podcast with roy is for all the artists
out there that are in the physical realm
who continue to hesitate or are in the
process of strategizing
uh getting into this space
and i hope it's also an inspiration for
others uh who
may not have even gotten commercial
success in their physical art world
but are not realizing that maybe nft
land is is an opportunity for them to
expand their their fan base and more
importantly and i want to get into this
with you roy
um
uh their creativity so without further
ado that's the setup of why i'm
personally so excited for this roy why
don't you tell everybody who you are uh
and what you do and then we'll get into
it
well thank you gary um yeah i mean i'm
an artist
i've been doing it since some little kid
uh grew up in israel in jerusalem
pretty much
the way i got to new york is through a
student exchange program i study in
cooper union
and then i stayed here in new york i was
focusing uh building my career here i
thought new york is one of the greatest
city uh to really and give a stage to
artists and the sky's the limit over
here and that's why i'm here
um i try to to make you know to make my
art
in different places around the world but
i feel like new york is the best spot uh
to create it
so i you know i've been painting all my
life so
what is your earliest memory of painting
earliest memory of my
painting is
actually seeing my father when i was
probably
four
years old five years old
see my father starting a painting from a
white canvas completely
and then bringing life
to the canvas and painting i remember
painting like clowns and i was like
really impressed about that i can and
that was fascinating to me so my father
stopped painting when i was uh
around that age
he stopped he stopped painting because
you know living is living in israel it
was difficult back then to be to you
know to make a living yeah and when he
had me and my brothers and we have four
brothers
he had to find like um
a real a real child exactly yeah so but
that's so it's kind of like
it's seeing that it was always
fascinating to me by the way real quick
i'm sorry
one of the biggest things that i'm
excited about when i wrote crush in 2008
i was excited that people that had
hobbies
they liked star wars they liked honey
they liked
sneakers or rock climbing that they were
going to be able to become an influencer
on youtube
and make a living
for me no question one of the biggest
things about the nft space is
your father didn't get to live out
probably his true calling
right you know i think about your father
i think about what this set of t space
means
you know it
too many people focus on wild commercial
success millions
i think about
thousands meaning
if if nfts existed at this time when
your father was at that age maybe five
years before then he might have been
able to build a little bit of a
following and he might have been able to
be a gentleman who made a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year selling nfts and
that would have provided for his family
and he could have lived his dream
instead of getting a real job which i'm
sure when you're an artist when you're a
painter
no
and that's in your heart
there's no job you're gonna get that's
gonna fulfill your soul the same way no
matter how much you even stumble on
something else you like i agree i agree
100 and i think you know it's it takes
me also to another if you look at
movements in art because i see that this
nft what's going on right now i see it
as a movement a new movement in art
it wasn't any movement for a while and
the reason i'm saying it is you know a
lot of artists was leaning on on
conceptual art pop art different kind of
movements
but
in our generation like it wasn't a major
movement in that and the reason i'm
saying movement is because
was the last big movement like graffiti
i would say yeah street art was like the
thing but if you think about it basquiat
was doing it back then
then what happened is
i think uh people right needs to artists
needs to speak to their own you know
agenda and create whatever to create
because
once you have like that big movement
and you know the top
artists in the game
uh leading that that's kind of like an
issue because
uh you pretty much you you don't have a
piece of the cake you're just enjoying
the crumbs
so
but what i see right now with what's
going on with technology right now if
you compare it to movement back then uh
back then you had like 10 maybe 20
artists sitting together thinking about
an idea and a concept behind their
movement they're all working on the same
kind of work
and then now
you can have because of technology
the outreach is huge you can have tens
and tens of thousands of people creating
that movement they all inspired one each
other
and and i think it's i think it's
incredible because the opportunity is
huge the movement is huge the community
is huge and that's where i'm coming
right now from i want to create when i'm
doing those this nft project right now
i want my community i want to be there
for my community i want i want you know
answer questions i want to you know uh
have like a nice boxing uh
with somebody just to understand and you
mean verbally when you say boxing you
mean you know
bouncing ideas off each other
challenging each other yes i understand
that right right i want to go back
further i want to really make this for
the artist today
more than maybe the nft enthusiast which
has gotten plenty from me um
so your father and you remember very
early your father so then you by 6 7 8
are you just painting yes i've been
painting and do people say to you
within your family and outside your
family hey you're good does it like
happen right away for you at a young age
so so i'm coming from from
i'm not coming for money
yeah for me uh
a compliment was everything if if
somebody tells your father my my parents
actually support me this my entire
career symbol since i'm a little kid
that was my fuel that was my
you know gas to continue and continue
creating but i remember you know back
then in tel aviv you know jerusalem i
i've been painting all my life right
since i'm a kid but by the age of 16 to
18 i created my own style of work after
i took inspiration from a lot of artists
and work with my technique and and tried
to really paint like any already artists
out there and then i started creating my
own stuff i remember going to galleries
and you know one of the galleries that
went in tel aviv i showed the guy the
portfolio handed it in his hand i said
check you know check out my work what do
you think the guy flipped two pages
closed the page and sent it to send back
give back to me and said it's not for me
so that was for me uh pretty much um
every time i got the negative response
it actually made me even
work harder and push myself harder
and and continue because
i know i do i didn't took no as in as an
answer like and trust me i got a lot of
no's in my career to get to wherever
do you remember your first snow or was
that one that you just told the story
the most maybe it wasn't the first one
but it was such a aggressive no that it
just sticks with you exactly that was
one of them like you know you think you
you know you're putting time into
something and then you get that no
answer and
that's really it's like a slap in the
face but
but i built i built so much uh from that
you know i'm i'm actually happy i got
that no
oh i'm
roy i mean i still am looking for news
exactly i prefer no to yes i agree i
really do i'm
incredibly motivated
um
by both which is why i'm motivated but
but i definitely
i enjoy a good no
i mean there's a lot of people listening
right now that think nfts are stupid and
are a scam and or a fad
and i'm incredibly motivated by knowing
that
right now the nft landscape is very
focused on the collectible with a little
bit of utility i know long term the
technology is more about the utility
with a little bit of collectibility but
i know it's going to be here forever
just like i knew the internet and social
media would be
okay so 1618 you're starting you've kind
of found your style you're going around
galleries you're getting some no's guts
now tell us the first kind of
commercially successful moment what was
the first moment so i think where it
wasn't just your mom and dad saying
you're good yeah yeah yeah so i went
i went to the army for three years in
israel
and i remember the first day that i got
released from the army i looked in the
newspaper i just saw a flight to it i
said i'm going to the first flight
whatever it is i saw a flight to to
france
uh and i went there i went with my
portfolio i remember seeing like walking
and seeing a very cool gallery and went
inside the gallery it was uh a show of
mirror and i started handing you know
showing people my work trying to hustle
my moments see what people really think
about my work and all of a sudden i met
the owner of the gallery and he got very
excited and it's like
and i was like it's the first time that
somebody really recognized my work and
really
loving it and said immediately he said
with the you know and i didn't spoke any
any english back then and or french
and we kind of communicate with our
hands hands and face yes and the guy
told me let's let's do a show let's do a
show together and then i did a few shows
back then i was painting in france and
then i had to go back so that was like a
big deal for me how long were you in
france i was probably a year and a half
or so creating a few
uh uh
very uh cool exhibitions it was very you
know i felt like i'm on top of of the
game then and then i got back to israel
and i studied in israel for or
you know solely art academy
and from that point i went to new york
for a student exchange i knew i wanted
to go to new york and study here so i
study in cooper union
and
and i invest everything i have in my art
like i go all in i'm trying to do the
best art that i can every time i'm doing
anything so
very quickly new york uh suck all my
money and i got to a point that i had
500
in my bank account and i was like okay
what do i do and i met a guy over here
in new york and and he said listen you
know in soho you can put over the
weekend you can have hang your work uh
on just on the street and see what
people think and you can sell it it's
actually legal to do that back then so
i took two of my paintings
i i hang them on i remember spring on
broadway back then was casey barry now
it's nike town and and
i s a bunch of people walk and and
really
admire the work yeah and then
then a guy came and and
reached over and said listen
i'm building this uh
restaurant in in vegas tau
in vegas back then it was jason strauss
and then he tells me would you like to
do my art the art pretty much for the
restaurant and then i said
yeah i mean i don't know anything about
tao of it i mean no vegas but then i
started you know understanding more what
what's what it's all about and i did
those art pieces so wait a minute i
don't know this story so you're telling
me you're on the corner of a street
because somebody tells you you can put
up two two paint you can put up art yeah
you're hanging out you're getting some
good feedback for a couple hours and
then some guy comes along
looks at it
and just looks you in the face and says
do you want to do the art for me in my
vegas restaurant
exactly like that
wow
i know jason and so
so you're telling me that that moment
really was a game changer yes it was
that was the big break that was the way
for anybody listening this is why new
york is new york yeah because the people
that are walking by the street are
people that are building like you know
restaurant empires
exactly
so jason says that jesus
did you sell that did you sell those two
paintings that day i i did i did or how
much do you remember it was probably
like uh 500 bucks a piece and you were
pumped yeah i was like walking like a
peacock pretty much feeling i want the
water then yeah tripled your
and the most important it gave me a few
more a few more months to live in new
york continue my dream so i was like i
was
i was always what year what year was
this
2005 i would say 2000. and how old was
25 i was 24 5 24 24 5 something like
that
and
you know putting the work in vegas all
of a sudden you know
i didn't like i'm getting i'm getting
like
by mail i got to remember like a
magazine and i see on the cover pharrell
took a photo with in the background is
my painting in vegas so that was like a
big deal you know i'm like you know so
that's that's the beauty of new york
like you you said new york you start
your day you never know how it ends yeah
you know
so that was like
how how many paintings did they buy for
town they bought like
two or three paintings three paintings
overall do you remember what you charged
them
uh
i told them whatever you want to give me
give me i don't mind
i think it was like overall
nothing it was it was like a few
thousands
but for me it's huge like for me i don't
care about the money when i work i don't
think about it
i just want to i want a stage and my
recommendation for artists
no matter if you get a no in a gallery
or in school they're trying to put you
in a box and all that moment
don't let it kill you like like
show your work it can be on the street
it can be in restaurants it can be
anywhere and now it's actually a little
even even easier in a way not easier but
more no no easier i know where you're
about to go of course because you should
you could you could dm 600 influencers
who have 4 million followers
i like what you do i'm an artist
do you want this painting if you do i'd
like you to take a picture with me in
your instagram main feed and don't
delete it in 24 hours you can absolutely
send that dm by the way people sometimes
say gary i need more practical advice
there you go dm if you're an artist
physical
you know even nft don't do what a lot of
spam people do which is airdrop into
peop influencers wallets and then claim
that they're supporting it that happens
to me it happens to others it's it's a
terrible tactic it's cheap but if you dm
somebody physical art or nft and say hey
i'm a fan of your comedy i'm a fan of
your modeling i'm a fan of your athletic
ability i'm a fan of your business
advice i'm an artist if i'd love to give
this to you but in return i'd like you
to post it in your main feed or in your
story or in your make a tick tock with
it
you know one person's piece of content
can start the process no different than
jason strauss but you know giving you a
chance to hang some art in town exactly
exactly
and then from that point by the way
after jason we spoke about date eighth
and sugarman then i met ayton
through
a denier and i remember
ayton was opening this restaurant with
justin timberlake and then he saw that
i'm a painter in the whole nathan eva
you know gives a lot of love to art
because of his grandma was a big in art
and yes it's is
so you know aitan is my
my my best friend uh for so many years
and
i started working and doing you know
some restaurant like i started to design
restaurant all of the sunsets and clubs
and things like that and the reason i
did it i wasn't a designer i'm an artist
but the reason i did it is because i can
expose it first
exactly a stage to show my work to put
my painting as a focal point in the
space and that was my kind of like way
to get in i actually think when i look
at your career from afar again because i
would hear things from italian things
that it should like you know
you were putting paintings and designing
in
restaurants that also had a lot of
a-listers and influencers running
through the place i assume some of the
other crazy things that happened in your
career happened because those
individuals first got a glimpse of your
stuff in those locations
yeah definitely i mean i made jay-z and
ayton's restaurant we did like it was a
cool night i remember we had like a
party i think you were there too by the
way back then but we
uh
oh southern hospital yes
yes kimberlyn's birthday exactly yes and
then i saw um
i saw jay and and he asked you know
what's what's up and stuff and so i
started showing him a few pieces and
then
he fall in love with two pieces send it
send it to me immediately tomorrow to my
office that was like another moment and
then i met and then
you know basically that's how i got uh
to work with rihanna because jay-z was
collecting my uh two of my paintings
that i sent to his office was in his
office and rihanna member saw those
works after she recorded the uh auntie
uh uh album and and she went to this to
this to this to the office and so one of
my paintings was the kid with a crown
and the braille um on top of that so
she saw that she didn't she didn't ask
jay about it she called sierra
our uh creative director and and they
were looking to find the rs to find me
through a gallery that i was showing in
berlin
and then she
you know she reached over and the guys
you know call me guy for rihanna is
looking
for you and
can we give her your number so i was
like yeah of course
and then we i remember recalling and and
then we met
and
and then that's how pretty much
i did the the art for rihanna's album
cover
uh uh she believed in my concept and and
you know my concepts it's all about you
know stands for human equality
the the crown over the eyes
symbolizing that that everybody's equal
everybody's the same no matter where
you're coming from
you know you you deserve a big chance in
your life everybody have a dream follow
your dream continue with your dream
don't let
people you know down you or doubt you
and things like that just go with your
dream you deserve it so everybody for me
is equal and that's my message through
art
um
saying that and and give people a chance
to be
you know a part of the work for example
in cooper union i remember
when i came to new york
i was uh
overstimulated you know so many people
in new york coming from a small town in
jerusalem smaller neighborhood
so i came and i was like okay i need to
forget what i saw till now
so i pretty much blindfolded myself uh
blindfold my eyes for a whole week
um and i wanted to reborn pretty much
reborn to light
reborn in in in the way i think reborn
in the way i saw things before
so um
i started working and the first
uh things that came to my mind if i want
to start
seriously creating art i want to start
with giving people who cannot see visual
art an opportunity to to to to enjoy art
so i started uh um
creating those uh i wrote poetry
and i translated into braille
and i and i sculpturing you know the
braille on top of the canvas and i let
people who are blind people that lost
the visual people in visually impaired
to touch the work and experience uh
a painting you know and and and that for
me was was uh was everything because all
of a sudden
nobody was nobody was left out nobody
left out exactly that's it i understand
and and and you know it's funny again
we've never really gotten a lot of time
together so
even the jason strauss story i didn't
know i was aware that you worked with
rihanna but i didn't know how it all
went down i'm now pumped because i was
at that party where you saw that now i
have a feeling i have a connection to
it i don't i don't think i really
understood the level of gravity
behind where i think you're going with
your project i knew you know i knew that
when you told me you were going to do an
nft project my brain went to the tom
sachs place stephen ray who you know
who's uh
got
brain vomit sarah bauman who does women
of weapons mumbot i love her work
all these physicals who went into
nft land that has been a big thesis of
mine
you know i i still believe you know vito
schnabel who i know we did some stuff
with artificial i still believe
that
um
the artists that are winning emerging
and are winning
in the real world have the biggest
canvas pun intended to be successful in
nft land you
you besides tom sacks you're further
along in your physical art career than
the other people i mentioned
you know
i i i just have watched you grind from
afar through mainly through eitan's
stories so i had a lot of confidence
when you when you reached out and said
hey i'm gonna do this what do you think
i have even more confidence now 25
minutes in because i don't think i
i have a little bit of a sense of where
you're going creatively with your
project actually where are you i
actually don't know this where are you
with the project how far away are we and
more importantly can you build on what
you just said because i know you're
going a little bit with this crown
braille thing explain it for me please
yeah so
uh i guess six years ago right i i've
been working on technology and and one
thing about technology that i want
people to know
is
don't like i remember when people built
uh uh you know you start photoshop came
out like way way back
and people using those uh effects and
and and filters
uh i was facing fascinating to create my
own filters my own uh filters to
photoshop now you're creating something
completely new and different
uh by doing that so yes so i taught
myself to to program and to to
communicate with those uh program and i
taught myself any program out there so
six six seven years ago i started to
working on an idea i spent a lot of time
in japan back and forth and
and i you know
i knew that uh that uh that you know
technology in art is is is a is a big
and it's going to get very big very soon
so i had this idea
to open a museum
institute over here in new york and it's
pretty much digital museum
that i pretty much create my own art
over there and wanted to do something
very big then covet hits
and then when colvin hates after three
work three years of work on this
specific museum here in new york i said
you know what
what do i do now so i had this vr set
that i bought this oculus set
play with that a little bit was born you
know during beginning of covet then i
said i want to build everything that
they did
for the physical museum and build it in
virtual yeah so now
so now it calls metaverse back then it
was just to create like a a virtual
virtually exactly for for people to
enjoy art and really walk in
and see my uh installations so that
become metaverse
right now and then
i remember uh ethan calls me a a
a year and a half ago or something and
it tells me you know
do you know anything about the nfts i
said no idea what's nft is say you know
you should google and look into it so it
was maybe two three articles out there
um it was and i think while i'm reading
about it i'm i'm understanding that this
is what i do right now i'm actually
working
creating a digital art
creating a metaverse
and the access to the multiverse is to
do
the the avatars and those are my ten
thousand nfts my ten thousand nfts are
building a mu a community that can come
and enter
to the metaverse
to the mega moon the name of the
metaphor is mega moon uh uh and and the
kids are the crown kids
uh the ten thousand and the idea is to
to
these crown kids are back to the crown
with the braille on it that rihanna saw
like that that's been in you for a while
yes yes yes yes
and they did i want to continue with
that that's my goal i mean again it's
stencil you feel like that you feel like
that is the thing right so for everybody
if you don't see it it's actually over
his shoulder if you're watching i don't
know if we're gonna clip this or this is
gonna be all
audio but
it's this golden crown with braille on
it that's actually covering the eyes
of the character which i think is kind
of interesting right crowns normally sit
on top of the head you've got these
crowns covering eyes
yeah because i believe that everybody is
a queen everybody is a king everybody
deserves a chance in art in life
you know working on their dream and
continuing what's the are the is the
braille going to spell out different
things on the crown or is it still spell
out the same thing for every of the ten
thousand characters for this specific
one it's it's it's yeah it's all it just
says all human beings are born equal in
dignity and rights
that we are all the same
uh um and that's what it says on the
crown so
because people you gotta understand
there's no back then
yeah maybe it was a king but the king
was never satisfied what they have they
always wanted more and more and more so
that's why that's not back then my
friend yes
the p unfortunately one of the greatest
vulnerabilities in society leading to
many of the
difficulties that we have around the
world
not just what's going on in ukraine but
many other parts of the world there's an
incredibly challenging game that
insecure human beings
can never be content or grateful for
what they have
they need more at the expense of others
exactly it's unfortunate
it's unfortunate and honestly i actually
have compassion and empathy for some of
the biggest villains in our world even
though they've created incredible
carnage and when i see villains of
course everyone's gonna think you know
point to putin and things of that nature
i'm actually going day to day i'm
actually i i take it day to day
somebody's right now listening to this
podcast they're gonna stop right now
because they have to go into the office
it's nine o'clock they're gonna stop it
right now they just turned us off
they're gonna walk in and at 10 16
this morning their boss is gonna yell at
them for dumb [ __ ]
that doesn't mean anything
and the only reason that's actually
happening is not because they made a
mistake on a task
but it's because the person yelling this
manager at 10 16 am
is deeply unhappy at home
and by the way not because they're an
atrocious person maybe they're unhappy
because their mother has just been
diagnosed or put into hospice so they're
hurt so they're taking it out on someone
else
there's you know there's challenges we
we lack empathy and compassion to why
someone got to a state
like that
we don't we don't think about that i
tell a lot of my friends if you struggle
with your parents
instead of being fully mad at them
take a step back and think about what
their parents your grandparents did to
them
right you know like we've got to be more
thoughtful about this i i love the
message of the crowns brother i love the
message
thank you and this is i mean
real quick real quick because i got a
little bit i was very quiet in the
middle i'm sure everyone was laughing
because i tend to talk more often but
you captivated me a little bit on your
vision yeah let's go back because i
really want to bring value because i
know my audience
do you i want to go business even though
i truly think you're an artist but i do
think i have a very big business crowd i
think this is important to me yeah and i
think you have 10 15 business and you to
go along with your art which is why
you've been successful otherwise you
can't so let me ask you this question
yeah do you believe if you do what's the
name of your do you have an actual phys
do you have a name when is your project
coming out
it's coming out in uh
i mean obviously
yeah i know like for example be friends
is in april i don't fully know when do
you think so the drop the drop probably
made mid-may something like that okay so
we'll just say
do you have official name for it or not
yet yeah on twitter we call the
the mega moon underscore but it's
the the name of the project under the
mega moon because the mega moon is the
metaverse and the the nft is living in
the metaverse those avatar lives in the
metaverse it's going to be in the name
of king you know uh crown kids
uh
crown kids so yeah so
so
talking business a little bit
do you believe that a successful crown
kids
launch in nfp land
will impact
your urn ability
in
the
in the
physical world
do you think you're
do you as a businessman
which
you know an artist needs to be a
businessman or woman
a little bit hey dad
thank you uh
um yeah do you think that it will
compound
your
physical like a very successful nft
project allows you to charge more for
your art your art will go up in price
yeah i think you know for me like i said
it's not about the money but i assume if
if the project is successful
yes it can make it it can it can help
the the the physical as well do you love
the crown kids so much because you
obviously do other art
that doesn't have them in there is there
a part of you
that hopes it's so successful that you
can do more crown kids
art physical like that there'll be so
much demand that that will become more
of what you make because you're so
attached to the message or
are you concerned that it's so
commercially successful that people only
want crown kids from you in a world
where you're an artist and you want to
do other [ __ ] uh um i mean it's it's a
it's it's a it's interesting question
because
i always try to do the best right i was
trying to to to to do to do something in
art i'm trying to to make art that is
relevant and and do make a change in art
in in
pretty much an art history so you guys
are doing a physical museum nft museum
in downtown new york yeah and the crown
kids nfts are going to give access to
that yeah it's going to be accessible
for early drops for events for talks uh
for for launch like we're building a
crypto lounge that you know people can
come in and be a part of this uh
community that will open a year from
today roughly yes yeah yeah
and in the metaverse the veteran is
pretty much ready we're gonna release it
on uh on on a 2d like a pc game it's
going to be on an app going to be on vr
and but there i created like studios so
artists that you know could come and and
create their own art in the metaverse
what i like about what you're doing and
i think this has been a huge thing that
i'm struggling with so many people see
the gold rush of nfts they're just
making something up today yeah and
launching in 60 days and then they're
surprised why it's not doing well yeah
you know when when was the first time
you made a crown kit or a version of it
how many years ago
oh like i would say
seven eight years ago it was the first
but the first first crown is a painting
was 20 years ago
right so to me to me
that right and i think you know as we
wrap up here for everybody who's an
artist or an entrepreneur and wants to
get into putting out projects into the
world i believe the reason befriends is
going to win is this has been on my mind
actually forever
when i didn't have a canvas pun intended
to talk about patience and kindness and
tenacity and ambition and all these
things that i have
i just used me garyvee i used me the
human which was not really in my mind i
never thought of myself as a public
figure i thought of myself as a
businessman but i got to a point in my
mid-30s where i was so pent up to talk
about these things i used myself as the
vehicle
now i have now i have a universe for
that vehicle it was authentic it's why
it's going to work i believe the reason
your project's going to work is because
you're
a
real commercially successful
actual contemporary artist but more
importantly for me personally it's the
fact that the project is something
that's been deep in you and has meaning
and i think for everybody who's
listening if you're gonna take your
first attempt don't just hire a graphic
artist to make you some pfps take a step
back and think about if your grandma
meant something to you or when you
played hockey it meant something to you
or a hero meant something to you or a
vision or a a passage out of the the
bible or the torah or the quran or
anything just doesn't mean something to
you
it will always do better when it means
something to you because you will fight
for it more
if it doesn't mean anything to you you
won't fight for it because you may
for example roy v friends didn't sell
out for the first three weeks
did not sell out everybody now wants
their thing to sell out in three minutes
let alone three hours
let alone three days v friends didn't
sell out for three weeks
yeah but i fought for it because because
i knew i was building it forever it
didn't matter
and look what happened now and what i
believe also when you create an image
that image needs to stays in your mind
so if you close the computer you close
your screen and that image stays in your
mind right
it means that you did something and i
feel like what you did
with the sketches that you made
i see the black cat i see all the
figures that you made stuck in my mind
because you have it in you you came and
you did it naturally yourself
spending time doing it everybody
everybody a lot of people made fun of me
because the art isn't great and for me i
was laughing because the art is so
provenance to me it is me i took the we
you know i took a long time thinking
about it and i took the week to create
it yeah and it was important to me that
the first version was me from my heart
my soul my fingers yes and i think
authenticity and prominence matters so
much and i think so much
many entrepreneurs like me will rather
hire a graphic artist and call it a day
which is fine you can do it there's no
it needs to be you and the extensions of
you you don't need to paint like uh
because i'm not you i'm not you it
doesn't that's not my art correct
correct
my friend thank you for being on the
show thank you so much i i can't wait to
see the project i haven't really minted
a lot of projects lately i've been so
busy but but i'm really looking forward
to yours and and i'm really happy you're
on the show and i hope we've motivated
some entrepreneurs and artists to think
about things from a different way thank
you thank you so much gary i love you
ciao
[Music]
you